hey guys happy Tuesday everybody you
know that usually means it's a destiny
to reset week the last week before the
DLC expansion comes out the curse of
Osiris which will be dropping next week
so of course we'll be back next week
with that but one more one more week of
just a destiny to proper I guess pre dlc
the season one's gonna end after this
week so if you haven't gotten certain
gear and things like that
there's your last chance to get some of
that stuff iron banner of course wrapped
up last week I didn't play that much I
only got like 13 packages I got three
pieces of armor I'm just kind of
unfortunate but you know it is what it
is we are about to try to do a nightfall
here I might try to get a third if
someone in chat wants to do the
nightfall hit me up
give me your battle tag and we'll try to
get you in here ideally hopefully you're
over 260 light that make it a lot easier
this week is Sabbath on song it's a
little bit harder than your normal
nightfall I feel like it's got time warp
fork anomaly
yeah I think momentum so the only way to
get in life back is by running around
and we can get into some of the people
getting upset about maybe the doubling
of xp for Brighton grams but someone
also brought up a good point that in the
past whenever we leveled up we only got
a mote of light so at least there's a
reason to kind of like level up whereas
in the past there wasn't really a reason
I suppose there's a nightfall
Wheatly the puppy says I'll do it all
right send me your battle tag Wheatley
you're gonna have to send it here and
then I'm gonna have to like back out on
my screen I think would quick to invite
you possibly or maybe I can do it from
here ad from here never done it from in
the in the clients
[Music]
what's up don't f sv does this game have
microtransactions s tax tonight i feel
like you said kill activision earlier so
yes it does have microtransactions
however they are almost i would say
almost all there's only one thing that's
not really cosmetic everything is either
cosmic either through emotes shaders
weapon ornaments the only thing that's i
guess you could consider
oh you're going okay well I mean I asked
you in chat buddy that works either way
the only thing that's not I guess
considered a cosmetic would be the these
bright paragon coins or not saying that
right am i uh fireteam medallions which
give you more XP gain and the chance for
more loot but these are only fifty
bright dust which can get pretty easily
by like just breaking stuff down like if
I broke down a sparrow you know I'd get
like I'd get a bunch like if I just blew
up this exotic one here I'll blow up
chrono glass who cares see I got like a
hundred which would be like two so like
everything is available in the game so
the free trial I think is coming up this
weekend too so I don't understand why
people are upset about microtransactions
when they're cosmetic it's in a lot of
other games if it doesn't affect the
actual gameplay I don't see what a big
deal it is personally however if it
upsets you then sure don't play the game
I guess
Candela saying Activision's dishonesty
about the XP throttling and increase
requirements really made me drop the
game again in destiny 1 all XP used to
get you was a moto light I don't even
look at the XP bar I think people just
see something like that and get upset
about it
if you want to be that's fine I
understand
like sure I don't know to each their own
anyways we're gonna do size down song
probably the last time for a while you
could sparrow this basically tonight
free trial is up according to Doppler
game if you want to check out destiny -
free trial as mentioned the expansion
comes out next week
Kristoff's iris I'm looking forward to
it there are a couple time warp
anomalies in here in this room there's
one up here
in the next room
yeah Bungie will also be doing a stream
tomorrow showing off some of the new
gear that you can get in the Christmas
iris so if you're interested I'm sure
you're gonna check that out so to get
time if you didn't know you kill those
anomalies and you tried hacking this
door at some point
don't saying hopefully it's decent
because lasses was kind of weak yeah I
mean they can't show off that much of it
right and there's only so much that some
units going came through
we'll have to see what happens
[Applause]
all right the only way we're getting
life back is of course to run around
mazzard panda please stop spamming the
cat
this guy
or just die a horrible death
-
reminder we are family
but I think when Christopher Seider
comes out I'll probably playing on a
console on ps4 that's where my higher
level characters are also that's where
my most of my raid mates are at so
it's better than it used to be
especially with milestones I think it's
tough too
one of the good things of about the
personal syrustey s user they're gonna
bring back heroic strikes which is
pretty important kind of shock that it
wasn't in destiny to be run away they
need to also add strikes specific loot
back into the game so that you have a
reason to do those strikes to kind of
chase some of those like strike specific
weapons or armor
[Applause]
and then we'll have to see what raid
layers are since they're not actually
adding a new raid to the expansion it's
this one again yeah I don't know why
this is I just thought about that too
and I was like was it just two weeks ago
and it was so I'm kind of surprised it
wasn't like brackets torn oh like oh you
know why we still haven't fixed that
other one
Wow
they get it off
I left an anomaly behind yeah there's
one up there I might have left one
earlier too there's more in this room
forget where all of them are I just try
to do my best
there's one over there later hole Howard
by void light the hive are calling
something to Titan no wonder they don't
want company who is this
the high can't summon anything without
those crystals tornado feels good to
watch focusing on games are focusing on
saving the Internet freedom sure
unknown fireteam P papi are there others
with you no just us down here
I
this is Oreos gifts
take a walk
yep I saw it coming I ran to get health
and then I ran into a trap like a screw
I don't know I'm an FN t are there
microtransactions y'all be trolling
today I like Briscoe Guardians so
there's one below into the left if they
didn't kill it it's one down there
should be like one
lives monsters
damn that nights still here
I gotta follow this for a long time
like one or two dollars
mistake
I wonder if he got the dump out
balls
all its own has to go grab the ball
okay that's generally what happens when
you have to slam the ball on this night
ball ball is kind of a class maybe those
Guardians didn't die in vain let's get
back to the seal we need to be some more
torrent nightfalls that's the fun one
you need to take oh listen we can use
the crystals to disrupt the ritual we
can beat this nope technically run
through a couple more anomalies in
nextdoor has the one that's
maybe song got the one behind the door
got that one behind the door our boss is
in the next year won't be able to do the
five minute challenge then just one hi I
know I always forgot forget when I fall
down that she sacrificed herself thing
we're going to make you proud take oh
yeah take off
alright boys
nice throw thanks
only he didn't close up his eyeball
though
there shouldn't be a lag
I miss all the shoulder charge so much
are you guys can shoot that
here's our chance
normally I would just go straight to the
podium but
those two stupid wizards that spawned my
diet every time
speak of the devil
Viji ah scape lock man three weeks in a
row I just need two loves and this game
won't give me girl Ellis
but at least I guess I can level my
aerials you guys don't have a cluster
rocket cut bear is really good yeah I've
seen to the past in curtain call so
that's that time we did the challenge I
think one of the challenges which is to
have five minutes left so there you go
the other things obviously this week is
zdz flashpoint we can start doing some
of those later Scarlett hi and buy some
flashpoint and then we'll probably call
it a stream after that here
but yeah that was the nightfall I have
no space for anything
of course you know there's PvP and stuff
too and the raid oh yeah fun times last
reset before DLC comes out I'm
cautiously excited for the DLC helped in
that you know raid layers turns out to
be a fun event that's not just like
visit the builders
so what now we're doing a flashpoint etz
we could do some PvP basically you're
just doing miles milestones
Manifest is attached
[Applause]
now you just farm and do your milestones
Wow I thought you targets nearby so it
was I ball somewhere a beach
the Kabbalah bringing in a fortified
mining house the antiques picks Brown is
that actually I don't know if that's
actually in the game yet
could someone confirm or deny that I
just got reading count that's it's kind
of is again like I since I played so
much destiny one I never really scared
at that XP bar since all you used to get
was a mote of light so the fact that
there's any benefit is already a good
thing not happy about it but
Oh
gotta love random let thing dropping to
kill you this little box here
five Bitcoin everyone says mark rose I
it's at an all-time high though it's
like a 10,000 which is insane because it
was just like at seven point five or
seven point eight like last week I have
no idea why
it's a farming game like warfarin yeah
pretty much
where they're raised in warframe though
now they have like a strike
got that [ __ ]
the fun thing here that you could try to
do is uh not actually have to take this
week you could just work away but you
could just another one pretty much like
really instance into the same thing Oh
try it again
it doesn't work we'll just go to the
next spot you guys think it's not gonna
work though
behind us can't
but yeah I always should have farmed
like more iron banner coins last
it's going haywire
not cool
dang he won the game of chicken was her
we cop the servitor and the servitor
took down the other fallen you've
smashed their hopes to powder again
excellent next one medicine there is a
grind yes but once you get to a certain
point it's not so much about farming are
we talking about warframe are we talking
about a destiny too
all forces in the field we have
sightings of red Legion infiltrators on
their way
let's chase them out they think they'll
spy on my territory
later met up
now
they're gonna be
the vents are blue it won't get away no
we're so close
zero hill saying I want them sub but you
shouldn't cover destiny though these
Deveny to feel hurt for the vs dude you
I don't know
I think people take it too far I think
that you think that's not all dare
decision 1 & 2 I enjoyed wearing this
game
there's other people that do - and
you're honest the XP give your complain
just about the extra things the XP thing
doesn't bother me at all because it's
worked like I said I played so much
destiny won that in the past we used to
get nothing when we leveled up for
experience so now you get a bright
in-ground pool like sure that's not a
big deal that there's more
the sludge looks like everything in a
circle
whom hate you at your company play
there's a saying Martinez I just said I
like playing the game actually I choose
to do this enjoy it I still think that
destiny for me our destiny to rather for
me has some of the best like gun
mechanics in the game and some of the
best like sounding guns in the game
that's me this is definitely not a
sponsored stream I come back acting
if you don't feel ripped off after how
Bungie launch testing one and then this
with destiny to game stop can reset my
copy to somewhere
mom that's fine man look people can be
upset about what they want to be upset
about like there are so many video games
out and about in the world that you can
play can be upset it's not what you
thought you're gonna get or not what
you're gonna be promised you don't have
to play it if you want to sell it
install it I personally enjoy playing
the game so no and I have people that I
still raid with that I enjoy hanging out
with and so you know because of that I
still have reasons and motivations to
play now I understand that some people
might have less motivation to play
because they don't want to do some of
these weekly chores that are in the game
I still like it
where's the new Asian that played the
demon soul jester I'm right here same
guy can't tell if you knew that I was
the same guy but welcome back her room
the VA wasn't taking the heat right now
Bungie would be feeling it harder okay
well what's worse TMI microtransactions
that actually liking once your gameplay
for XP King bumped up I think that's a
pretty easy one there just what's up
down thanks for the kind of website
before
facecam it's too small what's up
reach out thanks for watching the stream
currently we're good we did the knife
already we're just mopping up some
what's a rage challenge this week I'm
actually not sure Jarrod Jack coach
excited conjured I am Not sure it was
anything and they were trying to like
keep it with a schedule it what
both are equally bad in mind
I just think that like
[Applause]
[Music]
having a blanket hiding your shady
business practice until gamers I'm bill
I mean here's the thing like the
microtransaction thing in like games
like this or like Huck up here
I love overwatch right and I play
overwatch and I think that they at least
got the if you want to say trying to get
loot boxes more correct or in a fashion
that pisses people off less that's a way
right but why doesn't
overwatch getting you collect them if
people are so upset cuz it's the same
concept now I understand now with
battlefront that it has to do with the
fact that it's actually influencing the
game which is what bothers me the most
about that is that in action
when it's all cut like when it's
primarily cosmetics and it doesn't
actually influence your game to me it
doesn't matter
it's like you can spend it or you don't
have to I haven't spent a dime on any of
the emotes I saw in destiny too at all
and I've gotten them just from Brighton
grams I got salty I've gotten you know
exotic Sparrow so I mean if you just
play the game you're gonna you're gonna
eventually get it I don't know where
these guys just went either way I think
they wouldn't here Haroun Raheem the the
thing that people are upset about right
now is that I think they like increase
the XP amounts to get actually get a
Brighton gram compared to compared to
what it was before so now it takes you
longer to actually earn a writing ground
before
again you used to get a motor light in
destiny one and like I don't know I
don't even look at that XP bar when I
get a brightening grin was like okay
cool I got riding around who cares a big
deal we're gonna widen code
I wanted to go there I mean they are
gonna have the dotting event which will
probably have microphones I can see but
at least with that you get to play you
know potentially hopefully Sparrow
Sparrow recently I'm not sure if it will
be in in the dawning but that's when it
came last time so
hey I play overwatch they give you
freely boxes I don't have to buy
anything so many boxes pile up I forget
yeah well the same thing with this you
get look I have in my inventory for
Brighton grams and I just earned another
one like it's the same concept you earn
them like now what people are pissed
about is that it's slower but even an
overwatch XP in terms of getting loot
boxes and leveling up gets slower each
level you get - if I'm not mistaken
someone can write me if I'm wrong on
that one but it's like the same concept
so why are people even upset I don't
understand like help help me understand
why people are upset about what's
happening you guys
unless you're upset about DLC
but that's the case I'm sure we can
argue that but if we're just talking
about the XP things and I don't
understand it here Emily saying people
just love to join the hay wagon
personally I think Christina o'clock I'm
playing with friends I agree I feel like
I've been having to defend myself here
today because the haters have come out
but that's fine they're not pissed at
slower they're pissed that they stare
directly lied to about how much
executors got okay
again I don't stare at that bar down
there I'm already 1/3 of the way to the
next like bright Ingraham like I don't
know how many people actually were
counting their XP and like are that
upset about it I think it's just more of
like oh it's a topic to talk about talk
about oh I'm now upset because everyone
else is inside
but that's not my opinion personally it
doesn't reflect anyone else's on my own
so you can choose to be more upset
you just want the tangible seeing it to
be one city I get that I mean I just saw
I just think people are more upset about
it than they should be
I guess but maybe it's a bad presidents
going forward
they need a better matchmaking system
though there are games that you dominate
or just lose really bad yeah I don't
disagree with that one on the one thing
I will say at least one I feel like at
least compared to most other developers
they actually tried to listen to the
community and they'll react now maybe
they don't react as fast as we want them
to but they they are one of those I'm
sure most developers to look at red and
stuff they see it then you can count on
you that if you really wanted to
I'm gonna take us to do a crucible match
cuz and I just want to change things up
back with another little mutation now
goop I mean on Tuesdays I don't know
it's just easier to do destiny and not
you know I have to drag anyone else in
when we're pretty busy at this time of
year yeah exactly clip Ian if I'm saying
you're right sorry if I'm not saying it
right basically saying I played dozens
of hours of destiny too and I haven't
paid attention to that XP since I hit
level 20 I was surprised everyone was
mad too I don't get it
personally I think it's just something
for people to call out you know I love
you man but that's avoidance it's just
straight-up lie mini carrot all right
all right so thinking about it more
about what you said zero he'll I don't
necessarily disagree that it's
disingenuous to not put the X P like
number there and then come out and get
caught by players that it's not right
like that's not okay but for me this is
like personally it just doesn't bother
me so much now I can understand why it
bothers other people it's just what kind
of comes out of that or like if it gets
worse or if other things happen that are
like on a greater scale I guess I just
don't look at the X P bar and
you know I I get bright engrams when I
get them if I get them cool if I don't
I'll just like you know whatever goop I
actually might have to help some friends
this weekend do it for the first time so
it's possible this weekend I might hit
you up goop because I was gonna have
some people help me Sherpa them but
we'll see
I don't I mean Haroon basically saying I
feel like every time I come to gain SWAT
or other places it just feels like
people are whining just enjoy the all
the good games that came out this year
if you don't like something don't buy it
it's pretty simple yeah what I think
like it's just part of it is that the
that's kind of what the Internet has
become it gives people a platform to
share their opinions and I'm totally
fine with that it's just sometimes I
feel like people can be unreasonable and
like I want to say kudos to at least 0
Hill even though he's you know upset
about the situation he has been at least
you know he's not just like being toxic
and hating and like you know he's open
to other people's viewpoints which is
what we want right we want to open forum
for discussion where people can speak
their mind
not feel like you know people are gonna
attack them for it unless I will attack
people that are unreasonable though like
I mean
I'm about to say I like that I just
littered that with grenades
everyone saying yeah is pretty [ __ ]
though I've been trying to connect the
battlefield once everyone can connect
all right let's try to focus in on this
match here I have played super machine
while only because I guess iron banners
clash so I'm so used to playing clash
Oh Oh where did that guy come from no
we're not I'm not doing a good job
picking up stuff put on Ariel's real
quick yeah the problem with like
microtransactions too is that like
people have made so much money off of it
that there's like
oh he bought something from the Bungie
store during Black Friday that's the
Black Friday it's pretty cool
okay sure I don't that guys lagging
too many five minutes could go your way
could go there
Oh kill them
and we're again whoops now what the hell
happened it was close now we're not so
close because we're not picking up what
it is and they're doing a much better
job of it than we are I think like
ultimate team alone got ei like you
point five billion or don't go that way
Oh
the enemy's almost feel like I spawned a
chat that's our doing now and can't pay
attention to it because I am
we come back
fight again the harsh chirps of the coil
yeah good of war at war cliff
how do we do there 21%
[Music]
siress stuff isn't out yet goo without
next week is when the DLC will drop
can't answer that Haroon I would
probably get a call from EHRs but yeah
if you guys didn't know we're starting
are slowly starting to deliberate for
our best of 2017 stay tuned in the
coming weeks as we will be doing a bunch
of different streams we're gonna do
streams we're gonna do like a our top
ten we're going to count down backwards
obviously we're gonna go ten to four one
each day and then the last day will be
three two and one
those would be at 11 a.m. starting
December to 11 so that is in like one
and a half weeks or so
Kristopher probably no procedure I fall
asleep probably shoulda did it last week
when I was touring and easy control so
yeah stay tuned to that we're gonna
start doing our deliberation we want aim
being only AV
but I like that game a lot when you
leave the puppy
what I'm not even standing in it okay we
need the cap this enemy claims OB you
captured zombie you have your Gucci we
just got to hold these two spots that's
it
I will try to see what I can do it like
that group it's in my personal top three
I think I tried to run saw that guy
coming he's gonna try to take a which he
should be trying to do that's the only
way they're gonna get be back
I don't think they're gonna
grenade
get off my point got it
you captured really needed a grenade
their president zero Don will be
fighting that it's also in my top ten
personal talk time he's so hard as the
opposition to take take anything I don't
see sucks we stuck at sea and they're
doing the right things which is to try
to get a
oops
I wanna say it's vastly superior to
destiny 1 but I enjoy it there's some
nice quality life stuff but if you've
been playing destiny my not necessarily
be a reason food out there I am kind of
sad there isn't like a full-on rage for
take it thanks axe
jr. challenge like low life
yes has been a good year for the switch
now right the wild Mario always to Lord
have dawn
testing - is over it's as radical be
feared if you're talking about
that's the original version then yes
one minute won't be long now I come here
to get last has tits
all right good stuff good way to end it
I feel like yeah see how we did decent
performance
all right cool thanks everyone for
tuning in of course last week of season
1 for destiny - so just get what you
want out of that you know obviously some
stuff is not carrying over some of the
exact emotes won't like the spicy ramen
and I think the like Optima see the
armor that that armor sets not going to
be there anymore next week we're gonna
have a curse of Osiris DLC so come back
next Tuesday for that and of course as I
mentioned best of the 2017 for GameSpot
it's gonna start happening soon we're
gonna start doing our deliberations so
come back for that
as mentioned the game to pretend that we
reveal will be on December 11th which I
believe is a Monday at 11:00 a.m. so
come back for that and until next time
there oh there's no Lobby tomorrow we
are gonna be shooting some other stuff
so sorry about that and the lobby at
11:00 tomorrow but I think Friday will
be our next stream because the next few
days we're pretty much spending
deliberating
are trying to find our game of the year
thank you guys all and until next time
see you later
you